and then make well some of them like
that though like if they're masochistic
they like the idea of their woman being
having sex with another guy but you
didn't want to use the word cook I like
how you went with masochistic technical
term - we can call them cooks Oh Chuck
is compromised word though yeah isn't it
yeah there's a whole other stuff that
comes with that yeah it gets squirrelly
I thought it always meant that it it
always meant like [ __ ] hold like you
want to watch men have sex with your
wife yeah but then it got to where what
is it what is what is a so basically a
beta male beta male but there's so many
different versions of it now it's it's
become really freely tossed around like
a beach ball at a concert just throwing
cuck around these days yeah I mean I
think that's fine if that's why you're
into no judgement there yeah it's into
being cuckolded yeah if that's what
you're into good luck with that
just okay [ __ ] a man who's desperate for
acceptance approval and affection from
women oh now it's different this
desperation has led to the compromise of
his beliefs and values the desecration
of his dignity and self-worth and this
inability to stand up for himself
there's a 4chan right this and what he
deserves as a human being example
loyalty fidelity and honesty in a
romantic relationship okay okay look at
look at the example they gave hold on a
second I know John's always wanted a
girlfriend but since him and Mary
started dating he's become a [ __ ] she
spends all of his money and flirts
openly with openly with other men I can
tell it bothers him but he's so afraid
of losing her that he doesn't say
anything
that's a [ __ ] sounds like a male
feminist also wow I can't believe you
went there I don't yeah that male
feminist thing I've known a few that
were real creeps that were fake creeps
you know they're like on the side they
were what they're doing was they were
they're posturing as an alternative to
these men who don't want monogamous
relationships or would break the woman's
heart or not willing to compromise and
bend the will of the woman and they put
these women on a platform and worship
these women and I am the alternative and
I'm the powerful alternative and these
men are [ __ ] and then they try to
[ __ ] on those men and take those but all
does is make those men appear even more
attractive to these women secretly these
men these feminist men and these women
have these weird relationships where it
doesn't work and they're never sexual or
if they are sexual the women aren't
really sexually attracted to him so they
withhold sex and it gets super weird
yeah obviously I just generalized a lot
about a giant group of people's
relationships but what I've seen it's
just it's they they don't run fast they
can't pick things up they're not
attractive so they tried their little
weasels they're trying to find another
way in
yeah yeah I mean I think men who not all
men who call themselves feminists or
male feminists so in that I think men
who ascribe to women being equal that's
a good thing yeah and I think a lot of
guys will say yeah I'm feminists because
they think that's the right thing to do
that's the socially acceptable thing and
that's the way we should be but then the
ones who run around and say you know
really really push it and make that
their identity and really sell
themselves as male feminists those are
the guys I have an issue with because
like you said they're sneaky they know
what they're doing yeah they're not
being honest well you could almost
always tell but you you see them yeah
they're they're a type mm-hmm you know
they're just they're an unattractive
type they're not attractive to women and
they try to figure out a way mm-hmm like
how am I gonna do this what's gonna be
the way yeah I got to figure out a way
to stand out and this is the way I'm
gonna just what what do these women want
to hear they wanna hear that I'm gonna
say that yeah egalitarians great you
know someone who believes in equality is
great but as soon as you stat like
you're proclaiming yourself to be more
interested in the opposite gender
and more supportive of them than males
and even though you are a male mhm mhm
that should be a red flag that's a giant
red flag you should be into humans mhm
I like people mm-hmm I like people I
like I'm gay I like I'm straight I like
people
I like when they're nice you're nice to
me I'm nice to you that's what I like I
don't want you get discriminated against
in any way shape or form yeah but I
don't want to pretend that one group is
better than other groups except Asians
when it comes to Harvard the crazy thing
is with these guys though you see there
has been a trend where they actually
have a lot to hide and they usually are
misogynistic and they usually do abuse
women what's the scary thing I think
what happens is there's a certain amount
of resentment that from living this sort
of like fake life and having these fake
beliefs and doing so just to get to the
approval of women mm-hmm you know and
then when it doesn't work out there's
anger resentment and this just just or I
think some guys put it on because it's a
way of overcompensating for their own
guilt yeah that's true too probably yeah
it's probably a lot of different reasons
why men become feminists and very few of
them are good unless they're just their
idea of what it means is different than
my idea what it means my idea of means
is a little that little sneaky [ __ ]
mmm-hmm that's my idea you know why
cause I've just seen so many of them
yeah it's like look I'm sure some bank
robbers are really romantic interesting
poets who just decide this is a great
way to make money mm-hmm there's gotta
be one you know but most of them are
[ __ ] criminals Yeah right and this is
like how I feel about male feminists
like I'm sure there's a bunch of them
out there that are really good guys and
maybe through the influence of the
people they've been around they've
chosen to identify as a male feminist
and this seems to be a good way to show
that they support women and even if they
have to support women over men look
women have been [ __ ] over for so long
I'm more than willing to do that and
they do it with good intentions so
that's entirely possible but a lot of
inner creepy little dudes that are
trying to get laid and they they're not
attractive to women
so then try to figure out a way to
become attractive to women and they
don't have the confidence to just go
well aren't we all equal aren't we all
just all humans or
we're all different or work on yourself
to make yourself more attractive to
women
instead of deceiving them one of my
all-time favorite tweets that I read was
the guy saying I'm not going to describe
myself as a feminist until women tell me
that I'm doing feminism correctly he's
like more feminist than regular
feminists he's like so feminine 2,000
times ya can't be a feminist to women
tell me I'm a feminist
mistress mistress please tell me that
dude's got a ball gag on right now it's
like tightening it down he's putting
himself in the shackles but then there's
women like that too there's women that
pretend to be one of the guys like that
girl yeah there's always the one of the
guys girl people can sense it though
mm-hmm like I think other guys can tell
when a male when a guy's not sincere
about being a male feminist and the same
with girls can tell oh yeah you know the
big red flag with girls girls who don't
have girlfriends mm-hmm they're just
friends with guys they get along with
guys better yeah bet you do I had a
friend of mine who's dating a girl like
that and she all she had was male
friends I was like dude I might get out
now like this is not gonna work so tell
me what does that mean girls don't like
her
yeah girls don't trust her you can't
find any girls yeah that's crazy that is
crazy I'm not saying you shouldn't have
some guy friends mm-hmm but all your
friends are guys yeah that's a red flag
no I would agree with that and any guy
you have a straight guy and all his
friends are girls yeah no I know [ __ ] is
happening here right I just don't get
along with guys guys are [ __ ] I
don't like the way they talk about women
oh okay all of them all of them yeah
come on were you hanging out dude you
don't like any guys okay yeah it seems
weird so what did your friend do oh he
got [ __ ] around on yeah yeah yeah
she was [ __ ] all those guys that's
gonna say I was gonna say yeah of course
we're the writing's on the wall
yeah it was ugly too the way it went
down but that's how it is you know I
mean look people people are hos trying
to find their way in look what's what's
what's my way to get the most acceptance
my way to get the most happiness my way
and I mean it's fairly unrelated but not
necessarily to what we're talking about
about gender dysphoria about some people
choosing that as a path to get a lot of
attention I mean I think there's many
things that people do to get a lot of
attention there's